sabemos que si multiplicamos dos por
tres eso nos da seis positivo y como en
este vídeo vamos a multiplicar por
números negativos empecemos considerando
que se multiplicó un número positivo por
un número positivo obtengo un número
positivo escribamos lo aquí si
multiplicamos positivo por positivo eso
nos va a dar un número positivo
empecemos a mezclar números usemos
números negativos
qué pasa si multiplicamos menos 2
por menos dos por tres
esto va a ser igual esto podemos verlo
como si sumáramos menos dos tres veces y
ya tendría oportunidad de hacer otros
vídeos donde podemos ver el aspecto
intuitivo de esto pero esto va a ser
igual a menos 2 más menos 2 más menos de
genomma no menos 6 más menos 2 y esto va
a ser igual a menos 2 más menos 2 es
igual a menos 4 más menos 2 esto es
igual a menos 6 otra manera de ver esto
es que si yo multiplico 2 por 3 voy a
obtener 6 pero como uno de los números
es negativo entonces el producto va a
ser negativo
entonces si multiplico un negativo por
un positivo lo que voy a obtener es un
negativo
qué pasa si intercambiamos los números
si multiplicamos ahora 3
-2 bueno no debe importar no importa el
orden de los factores no altera el
producto
así si multiplicamos 2 por 3 es igual a
6 si multiplicamos 3 por 2 también
obtenemos 6
aquí tenemos esa misma propiedad si
multiplicamos 3 por menos 2 esto nos va
a dar igual también a menos 6 menos 6 de
nueva cuenta consideramos que 3 por 2 es
igual a 6 uno de estos números es
negativo el producto va a ser negativo
podemos escribir lo positivo por
negativo va a ser también igual a
negativo y estas dos son exactamente lo
mismo hemos intercambiado los números
pero es la regla donde exactamente uno
de los números es negativo exactamente
un negativo exactamente un negativo
y por un positivo y entonces obtiene es
un producto negativo pensemos ahora en
el tercer caso cuando ambos números son
negativos si multiplico y voy a cambiar
colores simplemente para hacer más
divertido esto si multiplico entonces
menos 2 x menos 3 y esta es la menos
intuitiva de las reglas en futuros
vídeos te va a dar una explicación de
por qué esto es así y como en
matemáticas todo concuerda aquí
tendríamos entonces que menos 2 x menos
3 sería 2 por 3 es igual a 6
tenemos negativo por negativo una manera
de acordarse de esto es que los
negativos se cancelan así que aquí
tendríamos 6 positivos de hecho no hay
que escribir el positivo pero lo voy a
hacer simplemente para hacer énfasis en
esto esto de aquí resulta entonces 6
positivo
aquí tenemos otra regla de oro entonces
si tengo negativo por negativo los
negativos se van a cancelar y esto nos
va a dar un número positivo con estas
reglas en mente hagamos algunos ejemplos
te invito a que los hagas por tu cuenta
ponle pausa el vídeo resuelve el ejemplo
y después puedes checar tu respuesta
hagamos entonces menos 1 x menos 11 por
1 es igual a 1 y negativo por negativo
se cancelan negativo por negativo nos da
positivo entonces esto va a ser
simplemente 11 positivo pongo el signo
de más para enfatizar que es positivo
hagamos ahora menos uno por cero esto es
igual a y aquí puedes decir guay aquí no
hay ninguna regla que aplica porque 0 no
es ni positivo ni negativo pero lo que
tienes que recordar es que cualquier
número x 0 es igual a 0
así es que menos 1 por 0 es igual a 0 o
si hacemos 0 x - 783 eso va a ser
también igual a cero ahora calculemos
déjame hacer unos más interesantes voy a
usar un nuevo color hagamos 12 x menos 4
esto va a ser igual 12 por 4 es igual a
48 y estamos en el caso
donde uno de los números es negativo si
exactamente uno de los números es
negativo entonces el producto es
negativo estamos en este caso de aquí
este es el caso en el que estamos donde
tenemos un número negativo por lo cual
el producto es negativo puedes imaginar
que estás repitiendo la suma de menos 4
12 veces por lo cual obtienes menos 48
hagamos otro ejemplo cuánto es 7 por 3
aquí hay un pequeño truco porque aquí no
hay números negativos pero bueno aquí
tenemos el producto de los números
positivos es el primer caso que tenemos
aquí positivo por positivo que ya sabías
desde antes de ver este vídeo esto es
igual a 21
hagamos un último ejemplo digamos que
tenemos menos 5 x menos 10 este es el
caso de dos números negativos que se
multiplican ya sabemos que negativo x
negativo se cancela nos da positivo esto
nos va a dar positivo 50 negativo por
negativo es positivo estamos en este
caso de aquí